good morning everybody welcome to this
talk on using Kafka for dotnet
development my name is Kevin Feazell I
am a Microsoft data platform in VP out
of Durham North Carolina also manager of
a predictive analytics team and I want
to show something really fast it's
called curated sequel the idea of
curated sequel is that I try to find a
link to five to ten interesting blog
posts per day somewhere in the data
platform space including database
administration or development power bi
Kafka spark the entire Hadoop ecosystem
are a Python and so on so that's curated
SQL comm so let's talk Kafka Apache
Kafka is a message broker that lives on
a Hadoop stack it is a top-level Apache
product which means that there's a full
open-source community for it
they make regular releases for this
product and there's enough of a
community there to ensure the support
for the future the idea behind this
broker is just like any other broker we
have producers that will send messages
to consumers but the trick around Kafka
is everything in this picture is
distributed meaning that you can scale
out the individual pieces separately
from one another and the scale is
approximately linear in terms of I added
new hardware I get approximately linear
growth in the capacity to explain why
Kafka is interesting first I want to
talk a little bit about why message
brokers are interesting so I'm here at a
development conference normally I
present these at data platform
conferences where
database administrators don't
necessarily know the value behind
message brokers so please indulge me
just a moment we suppose that we have a
couple of applications that want to
communicate and in this case I'm
inverting the normal paradigm I have an
application a web app that communicates
rights to a database we don't care
what's in the database it's just there
it's it's a requirement we have to put
stuff in a database getting it out who
cares so this works fine I set up my app
I set up my database I have a connection
string that points to my database and I
write insert statements
this works well until you get to a
certain point at some point we can't
push messages through anymore
typically it's because this really
underpowered like one core AWS or Azure
VM that's running our web application
can't take any more requests and so we
say I got that I'll spin up a bunch of
those VMs so now we have a bunch of VMs
all writing into our database and at
some point we've spun up enough VMs that
now it's our pour database that is the
bottleneck we say okay I got that I'm
gonna do this then we get spaghetti so I
have all of these virtual machines that
now want to talk to a bunch of different
database servers I can have a bunch of
connection strings I probably have some
manager in between that tells exactly
which database server to go talk to at
any point in time but I start to run
into interesting issues at scale one of
those issues is we suppose I need to
write to that database but database goes
offline what are the applications do the
applications I have to write to this
particular database we can say I'm gonna
hold the messages on this server until
that database comes back online whenever
that may be but then we may run out of
disk space on this server because again
they're really cheap vm's that we're
trying to spend as little money on and
now that whole server is offline that's
a problem another issue that we might
run or another way that we may be able
to solve the problem is to say alright I
received a message but it's gonna go to
that failed server so forget about it
drop the message that may be okay but
probably isn't okay to just arbitrarily
drop messages because sorry your final
destination is unavailable right now so
okay we put in a broker the idea of the
broker is that messages come in from the
consumer consumer still or excuse me
coming from the producer the producer is
still really cheap hardware
these really cheap VMs that probably
don't have much disk space this producer
has a lot of disk space its whole job is
to collect messages to collect data and
then eventually a consumer like our
database is going to read is going to
consume the messages in the broker and
then do whatever it does with them from
the brokers perspective we don't care
what the consumer does that's not our
job anymore
so now I've pushed the problem of what
happens when something fails one step
further I don't have to worry about
running out of disk space on this broker
because you know we're we're running
this on a server that's going to have a
lot of disk space
notice how I'm wishing away the problem
but one of the benefits that will see
with Kafka is that because I can scale
out this broker I can just add new
servers add new servers and keep adding
more discs and life is good what I'm
doing here though is I'm decoupling
production of a message I'm decoupling
the production from the consumption of
that message I no longer care who the
consumer is or who the consumers are
instead I'm just saying as a producer I
sent a message here and I'm done my work
is over somebody else take it from there
so the talk today is going to focus on
using Apache Kafka to ingest enrich and
consume data and the data that I've
chosen is flight data I take enough
flights that this is an interesting
enough topic to me
I pulled a fair number of flights from
the year 2008 that was data that came
from a contest and so is generally
available fairly easy for me to grab and
I want to know broken out by state this
was all United States data how many
flights did we have in 2008 how many
arrivals were delayed
how much arrival delay did we have and
supposing that I'm going to some state
how long can I expect assuming that
there is a delay that delay will be
let's talk now
about concepts typically a message
broker will act like a queue so what I
mean by this is that I have a set of
messages that are available for me and
now the consumer is going to pull the
nest next message off of the queue and
consume it once it consumes the message
it's gone for good consumer then pulls
the next message consumes it because in
height this ends up giving us one nice
benefit which is that the queue in a
steady state remains about the same size
so we can figure out about how many
messages per second we need to process
based on how many come in and have a
queue that has just enough buffer to
keep us going in the event that a
consumer goes down for an a
predetermined amount of time and you can
do the math you can figure out about how
much disk space you need but it has a
big disadvantage and I'll tell you that
disadvantage in just a moment the Kafka
model looks a bit like this it's more
like a log it's a file that producers
add to the end of the file and consumers
are really just hailing this file
they're reading messages from earliest
to latest processing through there so
the queue model has a relatively fixed
size in steady state the log model will
grow potentially in steady state but the
log model has a couple of nice
advantages the first one is I can have
multiple independent consumers reading
the same data so think of a micro
services scenario where I've got a data
source and I have a series of
applications that want to do small
things with this process like let's say
I have medical claims data my primary
application may be to take a claim and
then determine whether or not that claim
is payable I may have a second
application which takes a claim and
tries to figure out is this a fraudulent
claim so not only should we not pay it
but should we potentially go to the
authorities about this claim I may have
a
process which takes these claims and
tries to figure out which doctors are
most active in our nation patient
network I then can have another service
which does a completely different thing
all of these services can read this data
at their own pace we don't have to do
all of them at once and I can have them
be separate applications separate
services so they don't have to talk to
each other they don't have to know that
each other's services exist all they
have to know is where they can get this
data another big advantage of this and
so another big advantage of this is that
I can take this data and reread it let's
say that I had a bug one of our
applications had a bug at release well I
can figure out where the point was when
we had our new release and revert back
to that point and reprocess this data
now I as a developer have to write the
code that can handle rereading this
message and ensuring that I handle it
appropriately so this is not just free
I'm gonna take any application it will
automatically do this but you know we're
developers we're smart we can do these
things so the brokers job is to foster
communication producers put messages to
US consumers read messages from us and
this broker is running the Apache Kafka
stack specifically on a broker we have a
concept of a topic so topic is just a
logical container the subject it's we
can think of it as a queue within each
topic we have partitions partitions are
the physical implementations on a
particular Broker of a topic so think of
this as a file on some servers file
system we insert records into a topic by
way of inserting into an appropriate
servers partition now this producer may
care where the record goes
maybe the producer wants it to go into
partition one and then maybe their next
record also goes into partition one and
their next one then goes into partition
two alternatively we may have a model
where the producer says I don't care
where this partition goes or excuse me I
don't care where this message goes just
round-robin distributes so that I can
send you messages as quickly as possible
have some broker available and whichever
one picks up my message first that one
gets the message it's your choice you
get to choose whether or not you're
going to distribute my partition or
whether you're going to distribute
across partitions with advantages and
disadvantages around performance versus
the ability to distribute data so these
producers already mentioned they're the
ones pushing messages the other side we
have consumers so a consumer will read
data from a topic more specifically a
consumer will read data from one or more
partitions so here I can have a set of
consumers that read each of the
partitions individually or I may have go
back to read
I may have one consumer that's going to
read all of the data the way that I can
bind them together is with this notion
of a consumer group so think of a
consumer group as one or more threads or
instances of your application as
performing some process so in this case
I have four instances for maybe four
vm's maybe four threads on a single VM
maybe some combination but these are
independent these are independently
reading the partitions I also have a bit
of a an interesting scenario here
because you know I showed that color
based highlighting
well if you have a consumer group more
consumer groups than you have partitions
or excuse me more consumers than you
have partitions within a consumer group
then the one the odd man out isn't gonna
read any messages
so this scaling although each part can
scale out individually you do want to
think in perspective of having enough
partitions available for your consumers
to read if I had six partitions I could
distribute that across these four as a
developer I can choose whether to
micromanage those partitions or I can
just say go figure it out yourself I
typically go with the go figure out
yourself route because I'm lazy another
concept here we're inserting data into a
log and we have multiple consumers who
can read this data so our data has to be
immutable otherwise consumer one could
read the data modify it and now consumer
two comes back and actually is reading
completely different data because our
data is immutable if somehow somebody
makes a mistake inserting record one we
can't go back and change record one we
can insert a new record one but now our
application has to be able to understand
that you receive record one you may have
processed it some point later in time
you received a new record one you have
to be able to process that you have to
be able to fix what happened with record
one in order for us to be able to have
multiple consumers working in
conjunction with one another within a
consumer group we have to know where the
other consumers are in the group
alternatively let's say we have an
application that has office hours the
application runs 23 hours a day and then
we shut it off for an hour for
maintenance or whatever
we start out that application again it
has to know where it left off the Kafka
system will automatically store the
consumer groups specific offsets for
each partition and that way you can pick
it back up where you left off it's just
done uh behind the scenes you don't have
to do anything special to get that to
work now as as we go through this log
example you can retain the log
indefinitely you could have that those
messages remain for a million years I
actually have one topic that has a
lifespan of a million years I don't
think it'll this laptop will survive a
million years I don't think my Hadoop
server will survive a million years but
just in case I got that data in a real
scenario however you probably are not
going to wow your boss by saying yeah
our data is going to grow indefinitely
and we're never going to remove any of
it ever there are cases where that may
be a good thing but in most cases we
have limits in some cases you have
requirements that after a certain number
of years this data must go away I'm
familiar with Medicaid data in the
United States after seven years that
data must go away it's a federal
requirement so we can configure
retention times for our topics this data
can live for seven years after which
point it is automatically garbage
collected you can also garbage collect
at a certain disk size so we may say I
don't know how how long the data should
be retained you know we can have an
indefinite retention period but it can
only give you a hundred gigabytes of
disk space after which point the oldest
messages will get compacted until will
get destroyed until we have 100 gigs
remaining so all the stuff that I've
described even the the log concept this
is not new this is not unique this is a
pretty well solved problem and you can
go back to Microsoft message queue back
in Windows Server 3 5 1 that's a message
broker
service broker has been in sequel server
since 2008 I want to say maybe even 2005
there have been dozens of brokers that
have popped up over the years you know
like rabbits 0nq celery there's a whole
website qzo that's dozens of message
brokers that are freely available you go
into AWS and Azure and they'll have log
based or queue based systems for message
brokering so Amazon Kinesis and Azure
event hubs Kinesis by default stores
your data for seven days it acts like
Kafka but it's only a so excuse me a one
day retention you can pay extra to get
up to seven days worth of retention so
these are the concepts now we're gonna
drill specifically into Apache Kafka and
how we would develop dotnet applications
to communicate with a Kafka server
that's living on my Hadoop box so we
have a producer producers can have data
come in you know they can generate data
from whatever source maybe that's a web
server that's receiving HTTP requests
maybe it's a server that's receiving
messages from some other system in my
case i'm just taking data from a CSV and
I want to turn this through as fast as
possible my producer here is
intentionally dumb it will try not to
understand messages it takes a message
and it writes it out and it goes and
grabs the next message so that way I can
push it through as fast as possible and
I am going to kick off my producer right
now so that I can talk about it for just
a little bit and then we'll look at the
code and by the time I'm done it'll be
done so cool as a quick sidebar I am
using confluence dotnet library for
Kafka confluent is a company that was
established by some of the original
Kafka developers who were working for
LinkedIn they spun off
in confluent is now the paid services
organization around Apache Kafka they
have a fully supported dotnet library
you can pull it in from nougat and it is
the best library of the bunch there are
still other libraries that are available
with a nougat for connecting to a Kafka
server many of them are no longer fully
supported some of them only work with
versions of Kafka that are a couple
years old at this point so I would just
recommend grab confluence library and go
with that so let's talk about our
producer the code is an f-sharp so if
you're digging all the functional
programming talks today then you'll love
this if not that's alright it will be
pretty easy to follow even if you've
never seen a line of F sharp code in
your life when it comes to nougat I'm
going to have to wait until the
application finishes before I can show
you the nougat package but there's
really only one real NuGet package that
I'm using for purposes of running and
that's the confluent kafka package so
let us look at this code I've got just a
simple console application with a main
function and the first few lines of code
are fluff so that I can get a nice color
and stopwatch so I can figure out how
long this thing runs here's where we
start getting into more interesting code
I'm creating a dictionary so dictionary
of key value pairs I can say hey I need
to connect to a particular Kafka broker
or if I have more than one broker I can
list them all here so if I have 15
servers that I know I can connect to you
know I can list all 15 go try to connect
to at least one if I want to create a
consumer group then the key is group dot
ID so this one is called airplane -
producer technically I don't need a
consumer group here because it's not
consuming anything but for a nicety I
wanted to create one I've got a few
settings here that will help you with
pushing higher throughput and we'll talk
about that and near the end of the talk
where I'm giving you some quick
performance tips I have a topic flights
and I am going to write out to this
producer so to do that I need to create
a new producer notice that it has two
things that I need to give one is for
the key one is for the value so Kafka
will allow you to push key value pairs
in my case I don't need a key I just
need the value so I have a value of
string if you wanted to do partitioning
key based partitioning here's where you
would put the key and the key would
determine which partition you go into so
you may have something where I've got a
key for each of the states in the Union
and now I've got 50 partitions because
probably not going to be a 51st state
anytime soon so I can then determine
based on the state which partition this
goes into if I need to read by state
it's now a lot faster I don't have to
read through the other 49 states that's
one way that you can use keys to
distribute load but here I'm just round
robin inserting and you know let it let
it insert where it may I have a function
that I've created to load entries so I'm
taking the producer that I've created
writing to the topic that I want from
the file that I've specified so that's
pretty easy to do I simply read all the
lines in the file so this is then going
to filter out any lines that are blank
there's probably a new line at the end
of the file so throw it away filter out
the first line of the file where it
starts with year that's just header
information it's not important and then
for each line go and publish to this
topic so publish is a real quick one
liner that produces asynchronously so
write to this producer asynchronously
I'm not going to wait for a message
come back in this case if it fails if a
message fails I don't care I just want
messages to go as quickly as possible
you can if you want produce
synchronously so write a message
synchronously and and wait until result
comes back that's going to be a lot
slower but it is an option if you really
want to so as I run through all of this
normally it takes about four minutes and
I'm pretty sure this has gone past the
four-minute mark so my server is
probably a little nervous it's it's up
in the lights in front of so many people
but I'm gonna kill it right now because
I don't need it for the next step at the
end it would tell us that hey we
finished loading all the data and tell
us how long it took to finish that thing
up typically I'll get somewhere around
sixty thousand records per second
pushing from my laptop to this server
through this really really cheap travel
router in a realistic scenario I may be
getting I can push a million records per
second onto a legitimate server or
combination of servers as far as NuGet
packages go as I promised confluent
Kafka that's the big one
it will also install this this library
which is a C and C++
it's C++ under the covers and the
confluent library over top of it is a
dotnet implementation that makes it nice
and easy for us to use the rest of it is
simply helper libraries that I need for
my demos so a quick thing here is that
although I'm showing you one step at a
time
in reality all of these things are
firing at the same time so consumers can
read data while the producers are
pushing data and consumers can just
follow along as the producers right so
although I'm doing this serially it
really happens in parallel next up let's
talk enrichment
so our second
published application is going to take
data from that flights topic and then
we're going to push messages on to a new
topic but before we push the message
we're going to give that message
structure we're going to give it a
little bit more flavor we're going to
enrich it specifically some of the
structure that we're going to do first
this data came from a data set that was
published out of our so our has this
idea of na na is not quite null but for
purposes of our talk we're gonna say
close enough to null it's it's a non
applicable status so for example if we
did not have a delay delay reason is not
applicable and that's how that's how we
use this so I want to take those na
values and convert it to something more
appropriate either a blank value a
default value or an f-sharp we have this
idea of none which is also not in all
but we have none we have we don't have
one of these every record in this will
have a sort an Origin Airport code and a
destination Airport code so I want to
look up what those Airport codes
actually mean because that's not in our
data so I need to hit sequel server
because that's where I've got my data so
we're gonna hit sequel server pull that
data up and then process these results I
want to take my input CSV record and
turn it into a data set that I can
recognize turn it into a type a
structured type which think of it like a
class or struct then finally I'll put
that data is JSON so that my consumers
have an easier time they can deserialize
the JSON and have an object as opposed
to having to create their own objects so
let's look through that this is the
enricher application this is the most
complex of the applications I will show
today and we will start at the bottom
with our main function
so over here again a bit of fluff
followed by something that's a little
bit more interesting I am going to open
up a new sequel connection based off of
my connection string so let me hop up to
the top and say that connection string
is a literal that is just a connection
string of my sequel server you know
there's nothing absolutely nothing
special about that connection string
then I'm going to generate an airport
sequel type so this comes from a nougat
package F sharp data dot sequel client
and this is a simple ORM around F sharp
that will allow me to create types and
execute methods from sequel statements
including stored procedure calls so
here's my statement I've got an airport
stable and I'm going to select some
attributes from that Airport stable and
when when I do that I'll have airports
equal so this is a type that will give
me a sequel command alright let's come
back down to my application I need to
pop up here I need to create my airport
sequel type and then I'm going to
execute the the sequel call and take the
elements out and put them into a list
and call that airport's list so airports
list is the list of all airports out of
my database I don't want to hit the
database for every one of these flights
because I've got about 7 million flights
in here that'd be seven million database
calls and the whole point is to make
things not horribly slow so I've got my
list then I'm going to build a
dictionary building a dictionary are
really simple all I'm doing is taking
the airport code the three-letter code
that each Airport has and turning this
into a dictionary so I can look it up by
code and get the rest of the values
next up configuration settings there's a
lot more config settings than before
yeah I've still got my same starters
I've changed my consumer group here I do
need a consumer group because I will be
reading from the flights topic and I'm
going to be then writing to another
topic because I'm writing to another
topic I've got my settings for writing
and now I've also got some settings for
consumption auto commit this is how
frequently I update the consumer offset
so I may not necessarily want to update
that offset with every single message
that I pull instead I can allow the
confluent library to update for me at a
reasonable frequency so that I'm
reducing the number of total updates to
that topic specifically let me let me
show you for each consumer like airplane
and richer yeah I've already done this
before but airplane and richer is
reading from a topic and we have start
in offset and lag so we haven't here
this is just pulled straight out of
Kafka a topic that is specifically for
consumer offsets and specifically the
consumer offsets associated with the
airplane and richer consumer group and
the flights topic so in order for me to
tell where I'm at right now there's one
record in here and every time a message
is read potentially I may update this
topic you may notice that there's not
like 7 million of these as I peruse
through the list this is because in
Kafka there's a concept I glazed over at
the beginning and that concept is that
you can have automatic compaction of
messages so you can say given some key
only retain the latest value of that so
I can overwrite message oh those
messages automatically it's kind of
going against the log nature of Kafka so
I didn't want to talk about that at the
beginning but here it makes sense to
talk about now that we're getting into
the weeds so it is something that you
can do for your topics as well if you if
you know that you only should have one
version of something and you're okay not
having the true history you can use
automatic compaction and we've got a
couple more attributes here that help me
with throughput so input topic as
flights output topic is called enriched
flights too I'm going to create a
producer just like I did before so I
have a producer a null string and over
here on the right hand side I have my
implementation of a producer so my
implementation of null is null it's
nothing I don't have any implementation
my implementation of the value this is a
string serializer that uses utf-8
encoding I have a few encoding options
so I can use utf-32 or ASCII or whatever
I've just defaulted to utf-8 and I have
a consumer which now needs to work off
of a key value pair that the producer
used so I've got a null key and a string
value and I have to implement that I
have to deserialize what the previous
producer serialized so add a string d
serializer will take my binary data
stored in Kafka deserialize it as a
string
specifically utf-8 encoded string now I
implement an event so I have an event
handling my consumer has the odd message
event in the event that I received a
message then I'm going to perform this
function the first thing that I want to
do is process that message
so I have a function for processing
messages that's going to read the
message it's going to convert it into
something I needed to convert it into
and then I'm going to publish the
processed message on to my enriched
flights topic every 10,000 records I am
going to write out that yes I have in
fact published some messages so let me
kick that off right now and we'll see it
publish a few messages then I'll keep
explaining what's going on in the code
also notice the background is totally
different color that was an important
part of our our main function
okay well so every once in a while I
print a message so let's see what this
process is supposed to do process
message I hide that is going to take in
a string and my airport's I'm going to
call a function build flight taking of
that message in airports so let's check
that out a raw flight message looks a
bit like this so we've got some data
that says that on it looks like January
3rd of 2008 a flight took off from
Dulles in Washington DC and it landed in
Tampa Florida I would like to have it be
a little bit more human understandable
than this so let's split out the message
I'm going to split based off of commas
it is an appropriately comma separated
values list I'm going to get the origin
Airport which is the 17th element of
that array and the destinations is the
18th element of the array my flight will
say okay do we have an arrival delay
which is this guy right here turns out
that there's an arrival delay of
negative 14 minutes they arrive 15
minutes early which is great it's not
that common so we have some arrival to
life
otherwise if we if this was n/a then we
would make it a zero I've defined my
origin destination airports and my
destination state comes from this guy so
I mentioned the airport code TPA well
I'm going to go look for the item that
matches TPA I'm gonna go look for the
airport matching TPA and pick up the
state which is Florida and return that
flight so that was build flight then I
serialized that flight and I return it
and eventually we take the message and
we produce it so just like before I'm
producing to a topic I've got some text
and I don't care what the output looks
like I don't care if I get a message
back later on that says it failed to
insert this record in a real application
you probably do care but even then I
would still write errors somewhere else
I wouldn't have my producers waiting for
results to come back and you know we can
see that they're processing it's it's
taking its sweet time but it's doing
what 10,000 records 20,000 records a
second so that's not too bad so we've
pulled some data we've hit sequel server
and enriched this data and we're writing
it out as JSON I'm gonna kill this
application now I did 3.3 million in
roughly three minutes so a million a
minute again that's not awful for one
laptop running on one machine and if I
take a quick look at the enriched
flights topic this is the full version
so just like Julia Child I have the the
version that I can pull right out of the
oven that has seven million records and
I can take a quick look at some of the
data so we can start at the top and what
we have is a set of output messages that
look like this that there was a 34
minute arrival delay going from
Indianapolis to Baltimore Maryland
and that was one of
our flights so this is the stuff that I
care about we see the partitions and
offsets so because I'm arbitrarily
assigning partition I don't have it
defined in a particular order but each
partition will have its own offset so we
see you know offsets for partition 2
here's 1 through 9 we saw offset 0 up
above so we've got our data we've pulled
the sequel query we cashed that data
beforehand otherwise I was gonna make
seven million database requests and that
would turn this from 20,000 records per
second 20,000 records per second down to
a couple hundred per second so we want
to consume this data
you know we've enriched some data we now
have some details it's all nice and easy
JSON serialized information I can take
it and now solve the questions that I'm
intended to solve at the beginning of
this talk so we're going to read the
data periodically I'm going to write it
to sequel server so that I can perform
other processing as well here's my
consumer so let's set this as a startup
project over here in sequel I have a
table that is called delay by state and
if I run this I have no data in here I'm
going to once again connect a sequel
server and execute a stored procedure
because although I am using an ORM I am
still a database person at heart and
thus you got a call my stored procedure
so we're going to execute that procedure
and every once in a while I'm going to
post an update saying that okay we've
we've done some work so totally
different color this time so let's pull
down go to the main method so main
function dark cyan is the official color
there I have I have a dictionary of
flight aggregates what I'm doing here is
I'm this is really by state some flight
details let's see what those details are
those details are the total number of
flights the number of delayed flights
and the total arrival delay notice that
those are all summable values so well
might as well as pop back down to main
and have my configuration settings yep
we're processing stuff's going so we're
connecting to our same Kafka brokers
once again my new consumer group is
airplane consumer and I'm going to
connect to the enriched flights topic
the one that I pulled out of the oven
Julia Child style I don't produce
anything this time so I don't need a
producer I just need my consumer that
will deserialize utf-8 encoded data once
again because I'm consuming I'm handling
the on message so as a message gets
added I'm able to process it processing
takes the message value and my
dictionary of aggregates and please
don't tell the f-sharp people that
created a mutable dictionary in an after
application I still love you guys even
if you won't love me after this so we've
got our string and we got our flight
aggregates I'm going to deserialize the
message into a type of flight and call
that lowercase flight so type of flight
just explains what our data looks like
we've got an arrival delay in origin a
destination and the state the
destination state the JSON convert DC
realized that was just Newton soft JSON
then do we have a destination state in
our flight aggregates dictionary if we
do that I'm going to need to do
something with this I'm going to get the
current results if we do not I'm going
to create a new dictionary element for
this state so that's my current state
basically I'm getting this the state
that I'm in and I'm going to increment
total number of flights determine
whether the arrival delay is greater
than zero if it is that I'll increment
number of delayed flights again if
arrival delay is greater than zero I'll
set the total arrival delay and put that
into the dictionary so I have my data
that I've that I'm pulling and every
time I I pull that message I'm going to
process every once in a while I'm going
to write out a message that I have I've
read in a certain number then in my loop
I will write my messages occasionally to
sequel server so i will write every
500,000 records to the sequel server
using the write delays function so write
delays generates a new implementation of
my update delays by state stored
procedure I create a new table valued
parameter which is of type delay by
state type so this is actually a a table
valued parameter that I've created has
our destination state number of flights
number of delayed flights and arrival
delay so I come down and say all right
well as we go through I can add the new
values of total number
flights number delayed flights in total
arrival delay and execute that over in
sequel server I can pop over to my
stored procedure call and we can see the
table valued parameter that I've
specified and you know we already saw
what those elements work I have set this
thing serializable because I don't want
to processes to update the table at the
same time I'm going to take my data join
it to delay by state if there's already
a record in there and set these values
by sum by adding the value that comes in
to whatever is already there so I can
have multiple consumers reading this
data updating this procedure it's
serializable so only one can do it at a
time and if you're missing a state then
you know you can insert these states
where the destination state is null so
I've got data that's that's streaming in
and I've turned this actually it's done
streaming data so I can finish things up
but I've got this multi consumer process
that then integrates with something that
is not multi consumer something that I'm
purposefully making single consumer and
that pattern can can help you take a
process that you've already got in place
that you're expecting to work in a
particular way and fit in this
distributed system let's see so I can
read a lot and I can take that data feed
it into power bi and say okay so the
state with the highest average delay
that is assuming there is a delay how
long will you be sitting there is New
Jersey
Newark Airport is awful New York
surprisingly is not second because JFK
and LaGuardia are also awful percent of
delayed flights you know we can we can
see just for just for the sake of
schadenfreude ah only 3500 flights come
in to the Virgin Islands but half of
them that are delayed so if you fly to
the US Virgin Islands expect a delay
Puerto Rico is next followed by New
Jersey don't fly to New Jersey that's
that's the story I'm telling you all
right so let me pop back to the slides
and talk a little bit about performance
in the last 10 minutes basic tips the
first thing is maximize your network
bandwidth you may have tens of millions
of messages that you want to push
through but if you're trying to push
them through on a on a like 100 megabit
connection those messages have better be
really small otherwise it'll take a
while your fiber channel if you've got
it like a 16 gig or 32 gig fiber channel
you're gonna be pushing a lot more
messages just by having that additional
bandwidth available you can compress
data especially if you're talking about
relatively larger amounts of data like
you're talking kilobytes if you're
pushing megabytes of data per message
that might be doing it wrong so I'm
talking more of bytes or kilobytes if
you're wanting to push through a lot of
messages and there are fairly large
messages compressing them on the
producer side and pushing through a
binary stream will perhaps be faster
because it'll help you minimize the
message size you can also buffer
messages I ended up not really buffering
messages but yeah you can create a
blocking collection wait for a set of
messages to come and then process them
at once instead what I was doing was
just streaming the messages as soon as I
got it right as soon as I got it right
it interestingly that was not the
behavior that was happening over on the
Kafka server so let me pop back to the
producer
code so even though I wrote the code to
say publish as soon as you get this
message I've got a couple of parameters
here batch num messages and Q buffering
max milliseconds those two are going to
tell how long is my server willing to
wait until or excuse me how long is the
Kafka library that's installed for this
producer willing to wait until it says
okay I've got enough messages
let me ship them off it will wait for
fifty thousand messages or for three
hundred milliseconds whichever comes
first so I can configure that I could
set the queue down to one and say
literally every message every message is
sacred send it as fast as possible but
in a more realistic scenario I want to
buffer those I want to send them as a
bigger block because normally I am more
interested in throughput rather than
latency if you're interested in
optimizing for latency you want to send
those messages as soon as you receive
them you want to get them out as fast as
possible that will reduce the number of
milliseconds that it takes for a message
to land here but it will reduce how many
messages you can send per second by
contrast if your weight build up a bunch
of messages pass them all through at
once you can take advantage of say not
having mostly empty Network packets so
reducing the number of network packets
that you have to send in order to get a
certain number of messages across
you can bulk process these and get them
get more into Kafka in a certain period
of time like a minute but the delay from
message into Kafka may be higher
probably will be higher so on the
producer side we already saw batch no
messages queue buffering max
milliseconds on the consumer side we
have some waiting as well that we can do
fetch wait max milliseconds fetch
min bites so again how many milliseconds
am I willing to wait for a message a set
of messages to come through and I've got
them down here I'm saying I'm willing to
wait up to 5 seconds for a big block of
messages because I can process them all
at the same time I'm also willing to
wait for at least 4,000 bytes so these
are configurable you can bump these
numbers up and down depending on whether
you need more throughput or more latency
but it is the trade-off that you're
going to make if you don't want to make
that trade-off you can't add more
hardware and adding more hardware may
solve your problem because this is a
horizontally distributed system so if
you're seeing an issue like IO latency
or high CPU on your broker's add some
new brokers they'll be able to take
partitions from the topics and own them
and then you now have more Hardware
solving the same problem so those
brokers are going to have probably less
CPU less i/o requirements given the same
throughput if you're falling behind if
in other words you know we go back to
this Kafka tool and for airplane
enricher we have this concept of lag
that is here's the end of the topic how
far along are we what's the difference
between those two so if you see this lag
value increasing over time you might not
have enough consumers to handle all of
your load so you can add more consumers
to a group it's as simple as you know I
have that code I can put that code on
another server and run it as well and
it'll pick up as long as I have
available partitions that new instance
will pick up some some partition or
partitions and start processing
so wrapping things up Pachi Kafka's a
powerful message broker I love this
thing and this is getting you started
with it now there is another level past
this which is Kafka streams Kafka
streams is a streaming application or
streaming process that will sit on top
of the Kafka stack as messages go in you
can perform operations using K SQL which
is Kafka's implementation of sequel so I
can watch over a window and look for
what has happened over the past minute
what has happened over the past five
minutes have I found any events that
look like this it's a little bit beyond
what I wanted to talk about today but
that is really cool and I'm hopeful
you're interested in learning a bit more
about that if you want to grab slides
notes demos links to additional
resources they're all up at CS more info
slash on slash Kafka if you have any
questions at all please feel free to
reach out I'll be here for the rest of
the conference and otherwise hit me up
email Twitter however so thank you
everybody
[Applause]